everybody this is Tim Ferriss and I am
answering a question today that I get
very often which is what are you
learning what are you studying and it is
20/20 and I am an amateur learning hand
percussion specifically with this
instrument and it looks like a UFO as
you can see and it is known by many
different names some people call it a
hang some people call it a hang drum
there are religious wars about this and
other people call it a hand pen there
are many different brands many different
makers this particular instrument was
made by Dave berry BER Y super-sweet guy
in California and this is tuned to the
jaws scale and this instrument you can
think of it this is a simplified of
course as a steel drum that you might
see in the Caribbean which has been
turned into a casing with two sides and
this particular instrument is tuned with
hammering and metal work so you really
don't want your instrument to get
knocked out of tune unless you happen to
be a really good metal worker and I'm
going to demonstrate some basic features
of the instrument I am NOT a good hand
pan player or hand percussionist but
I've been very fortunate to get a
handful of very very nice instruments
this is Dave berries this is another
hand pan that I'll demo down here which
is made by Yann Boren hopefully I'm
getting that name right Jay a and B Orr
en in the Netherlands and I've had some
fantastic instruction from someone I
found on YouTube because he's amazing
David Cook hedeman I'm sure David I'm
screwing up your name yet again but
David K you see k ER h er ma and n and
you can find him at hanpan dojo dot-com
where he offers all sorts of online
courses and programs for learning this
instrument and if you want to see a
highlight of him just search his name
and Prelude on YouTube it's amazing he
has 50,000 plus followers on YouTube for
playing
hand percussion which is is a feat in
and of itself alright
enough said let's get into this so I'll
just demo some basics once again to
emphasize I'm not a good player but I
love playing this instrument and of
course I said without further ado and
then I keep on going with my preamble
but I tried many many musical
instruments when I was a kid I tried
piano and I quit
I tried trumpet and I quit because in
the beginning it's very hard to sound
good I did gravitate towards 5 piece
drum kit but only had a few lessons
until I graduated from college
at which point I was in a tiny apartment
and could couldn't make it work so you
hear there is a lot of reverberation and
the sound between these two instruments
will be very very very different ok so
you've got a scale this is tuned to hit
jaws which has a Middle Eastern sound to
it producing sound out of this and I
apologize to David if I get anything
wrong it's my fault it's not your fault
David is a machine he's amazing and one
of the best teachers of any skill I've
ever met
these are tone fields and I'm making
contact with my index finger primarily
around this portion of the tone fields
these two fields and I'm playing with my
thumb's as I get closer to my body
because otherwise I end up going chicken
wing and it's ergonomically very
uncomfortable alright so I'm playing
that with my thumb slightly bent not
like that
because that is how you make your hands
ache which I did in the beginning
[Music]
and this is the ding or the doom there
are many different words for it playing
that with this thicker part of my thumb
or index finger rather and making
contact with the palm so let me just
tool around on this for a second and
it'll give you an idea of what this
thing is capable of and I'll try to
produce a few different types of sounds
so
[Music]
as these very light notes are referred
to as ghost notes - really cool David
introduced me to those and these are the
tone fields and then you can get some
cool effects you can use hands like this
which you wouldn't want to hit on the
tone fields but if you wanted to do you
do that kind of thing there's a tuck
just that type of sound so if we already
use and these are my notes from some of
what I did with David if we were to use
a rhythm known as the I believe it's
holly g KH a lig I I unfortunately do
not speak Arabic but there are a lot of
amazing amazing rhythms and techniques
that come out of Middle Eastern music it
would look something like the following
and they're different ways to play it so
[Music]
okay so notice I'm doing 1/2 so the
right hand is having two points of
contact now you can produce the same
sound using alternating hands and just
the left hand so if you look at this I
[Music]
just switch the left so those are three
different hand techniques for producing
the same rhythm on the same surface and
which you use would depend on what
you're using and how are you using the
rest of this surface it's super exciting
it's so fun and you can use multiple
fingers on multiple tone fields so if I
want it to do something let's just say
like and I'll move over to this other
hand pan in a minute but
[Music]
so now I'm using these two fingers
together right David does all this
thousand times better so go watch his
videos but this will show you how much
it novice who really doesn't know what
he's doing can have fun with this
instrument and playing just 10 15
minutes in the morning or at night is
just pure bliss and meditation for me
all right so this is that surface Dave
does really something really fun with
his instrument this particular
instrument where you can see the surface
is very different on this side and if
you were say doing a performance on the
hand pan after 60 minutes of one scale
you might get tired of doing what you're
doing people might get a little fatigued
of listening to it so then and so you
can you can play with all sorts stuff
I'm less practise on this side but you
can certainly throw some novelty in
there so that is that is handpan one
from Dave which I really enjoy playing
and this is a very very different hand
pan from the Netherlands and you can see
looks a bit like a hand pan that took at
least one or two hits of acid it is
asymmetrical and the tone fields are no
longer identically oval so it's
distributed differently and another
difference that you'll find and I'm not
adept enough to take advantage of this
is there are tone fields on the bottom
so that you could hypothetically be
playing on this side and still
and you could take advantage of this
under the rim which is really cool
David's exceptional of doing this and
the way I'm or the orienting this is
generally speaking and those of you who
are paying attention may notice this has
more tone fields more notes and I'm
orienting this so that deepest note is
pointing towards my navel effectively
that's gonna split this right down the
middle so that I have my left and right
hands working on 50% of this instrument
right and so you very different very
different look and feel and you can find
some of these interested some of these
instruments are tuned with minor key so
it can have a melancholic sort of
poignant sound to it and others are very
upbeat and it's hard to go wrong when
you have an instrument like this tuned
in a particular wave you can kind of
whack on it almost any way you want it's
gonna sound pretty good so one and then
you can do you can just scale so you can
do seven notes eighth notes nine notes
something like and that could be a
practice where you like seven eight nine
seven eight nine or seven 7 eight 8 nine
nine and then there is a technique so we
talked about talk
and you could use that for any number of
rhythmic combinations so for example you
could do something like so slowing it
down and then if you wanted to throw
talks in there you could do that as well
so you can do something like
[Music]
all right you also go higher up and
within that you can really experiment so
you want to do something a little more
involved you could do you just riff and
it's very it's play very playful
instrument and you can also play sort of
a a a drum on its side there's a lot to
be done so those are some of the basics
I'll show you one more type of hand
contact and you can use all sorts of
David's quite good using this knuckles
but you can do a slap as well so I'll
set up
[Music]
get the lowest note in front of me so
you do something like so the slap I'm
gonna do outside of the toe and field
and you can do if you are so you're sort
of pushing into the instruments not a
quick release you can see that alright
so you might do something like so there
you have it folks this is one of my
favorite instruments it is a really fun
instrument to play it is unfortunately
because of the workmanship that has to
go into these it is an expensive and
strenght purchase but they're beautiful
and it's allowed me an entryway into
music and becoming fascinated with music
in a way that I haven't done before
because it's difficult to take a 5 piece
drum kit and put it in your house for a
lot of people it is difficult to travel
with 5 piece drum kit but when you have
something like this or many other types
of frame drum are other hand drums it
opens up an entire universe of
possibilities and another aspect of that
that is really beautiful hand drumming
has existed in every civilization past
present I'm sure in the future and
across the world so it is a common
language anyway there you have a brief
introduction to my love of this
instrument my apologies for any mistakes
that I may have made if I misspoke if I
offended anyone's delicate sense
abilities my apologies but thank you to
Dave Barry to david cacodemon cook hud-1
who is just remarkable and the many
people out there who are producing these
instruments and producing beautiful
music thanks guys
you